Welcome everybody to another holistic health hour.
We've got a bunch of questions that came in so we're going to jump right into it.
Remember that you can chat in your questions as well. Hopefully I will see the chat.
There's multiple chat bars here so I can look at it. So feel free to chat in a
question as we go here too. So let's start off with the first question that was submitted.
And I always remember that on our website for the holistic health hour,
that's where you can submit questions beforehand. Obviously there's people finding it.
So here are some of the questions. First question. How might drinking alkaline water affect
your daily, your body's hydration? Now I'm going to phrase this question two ways because
I'm assuming this person is asking, will drinking alkaline water affect your hydration?
Knowing that my philosophy of drinking alkaline water is not a good idea. So let's start with that
just so everybody who made out of asked this question understands that. I don't think it's a good
idea to drink alkalized water. The reason is that your stomach pH has to remain at a very low level,
a very acidic pH. And if your stomach gets too alkaline, all sorts of bad things will happen.
I have several blog posts of that. The need for HCl production by your stomach cells and the problem
with your stomach cells not being able to produce HCl. Very, very common, maybe the most common
thing that causes ill health. We always talk about leaky gut issues and inflammation in the gut.
Well, it can all start with a decreased ability to produce HCl. And what are you doing when you
take PPI's or you're taking even thumbs or something like that? These medications that block HCl
production, they can give you temporary relief from like an acidic burp up of reflux acid but always
no symptoms of acidic coming up your suffigates and affected your suffigates and you've
tasted acid in your mouth and this reflux issues are all from ironically a decreased HCl production.
You're not getting enough HCl production. It's not breaking down the bowl of food in your stomach.
And then what is there is being pushed up through the esophagus so that you're burping that out.
So ironically, you need more HCl when you get reflux and people are going and they're taking
thumbs, roll lades, going to get PPI's which is you're just going to, you're setting yourself up
for very, very serious diseases when you do that. So I have several blog posts of that.
But does drinking alcohol and water affect bodies hydration? No. So if you're drinking alcohol and
water, you know, it will be acidified by if you have decent HCl in your stomach. So there's no
benefit of drinking alcohol and water, all the alcohol and water companies that are pushing
the alcohol and water because it alkalizes your body. It's just completely wrong physiology. So it's
it doesn't stay alkaline. Once again, it's in your small intestine. By that time it's not alkaline. It's
just water. So if they're alkalizing it with using minerals to alkalize it or something like that,
then you're maybe absorbing those minerals. Typically they're not going to use good quality minerals
to alkalize it anyhow. So it can be even more harmful if they're using poor quality minerals,
then you are actually blocking absorption sites for good quality minerals. So I have several
videos on, you know, good supplements, bad supplements. So poor quality minerals and consumption of
poor quality minerals typically in supplementation, poor quality supplements or like grains and things that
are four to five minerals. So typically really poor quality minerals that can actually block absorption
sites for if you're eating good food with good quality minerals. So there's a lot of things why you
shouldn't drink alcohol and water. But is it affected your body's hydration? No, as far as
hydrating goes, it's probably the exact same if you're drinking regular water. So whether you're
acidifying your water by adding, let's say, lemon juice to it or apple cider vinegar to it,
or you're alkalizing water by you to prescribe alkalized water drink or getting one of those alkalizing
water machines. It's not affecting your hydration. It's just it's still going to be absorbed with water.
So it still is good for hydration. This is bad for your gut as far as alkalizing water goes.
Next question. I heard that fluoride and toothpaste and drinking water is not the same as the
type of fluoride used in studies showing benefits for teeth. What are your thoughts of this and the
misleading information on fluoride being good for you as opposed to highly toxic. So I wouldn't dispute
that fluoride, you know, using fluoride toothpaste and things may be beneficial for your teeth.
fluoride is, you know, in the classification basically, I'm a heavy metal and it will, you know,
be substituted as calcium in your teeth and it can make your teeth harder and it can possibly
even prevent cavities. I mean, I wouldn't doubt that. Is it the right thing for it? No. Is it toxic?
Highly toxic. So there's no way that you could even put in fluoride treatment on a tooth,
which I think a dentist can do that with a topical, you know, like a like they paint on a fluoride
treatment on a tooth. Still, it's going to slump off into your system and it's going to act like a heavy
metal. It could cost the blood brain barrier. It can damage neurons. It can be the cause of
neural microglial priming. They can damage cells. It's going to be stored in fat cells.
They can be the cause of DNA damage and a cause of cancer. So there's no way a person should be
using fluoride toothpaste. There's no way a person should be accepting fluoride from their dentist.
I don't care what it does to your teeth still, but fluoride is not the desired nutrient to make your
teeth harder. It's calcium in the right form to help make your teeth more dense and harder.
So no way, I think fluoride should be used in human consumption of any kind or human exposure of any
kind. It's highly toxic. That's why I put it in and I'm sticking to it. Reading about this product,
GC-M-A-F, because my friend is taking it at hope for cancer. I'm wondering why we don't all take
these types of things extremely regardless of an issue. Could these be useful as a preventative?
Is this something that can be purchased by other friends struggling with cancer at the U.S.?
So GC-M-A-F is a product that stimulates macrophage,
production, and stimulates macrophage attack to cancer cells. It was a product that was originally
made in England, years ago, decades ago, and studies were done on it that it was very beneficial and
it was injectable. So it's stimulated macrophage attack on cancer cells. Very promising therapy,
but it wasn't something that was patentable because it was made from vitamin D and through,
I think it was omega-9 fatty acids. So it was a synthesis of vitamin D and omega-9 fatty acids.
Well, that factory that was making that in the practitioner that was doing the studies, the company that
was doing it got shut down by the British Medical Association, which isn't much different as far as
their authored authoritarian Nazi-like function as the AMA and the FDA here at the United States.
So they got shut down and disbanded and information was taken, not a good seed.
Then a number of years later, there was a company in New Zealand or something like that that started
up making it again. It's not something that we use in our office because we don't do injectables,
we don't do anything that would be beyond our scope, but the practitioners that I spoke to that used
it were not happy. So they were using the original GCMAF and then they started using the new GCMAF
that began maybe 10 years ago and that's what to my knowledge is still available today. The
practitioners that were using the old and switched to the new said it was just different. It wasn't
made the same way. They weren't getting the same results. Now, I do realize that there's clinic like
clinics in Mexico that still use that. I think there may be even clinics in the US that still use
that. Understand that is just one therapy. One of many, many therapies that you could do to help
with a person with cancer alternative therapies I'm talking about. That's just one.
There's many more that I write about it in my book. There's many more that I comment on it,
have videos on our website. So do go on our website and look at our blog posts. I think we have
a well over 1,000 blog posts of different things with cancer. However, so the question is can a person
use this preventatively? I don't know where you would get that for preventative use. Personally,
I wouldn't use it for preventative use. I would use other things that would more naturally
stimulate my immune system. I would do things to help with detoxification pathways from a preventative
basis. I would do things that would help prevent the causes of cancer that would help another good,
really good thing to do is to do a full genetic workup. I don't have cancer so I don't want to get
cancer. Should you do a full genetic workup? Yes, that would be really good. What you see very
commonly with cancer patients is deficiencies or issues from a genetic standpoint with their
detoxification pathways. So if you can't detoxify chemicals like fluoride from the question
minute ago, things like that that can settle in your body and get inside a cell. Remember,
cancer is cells that are damaged. The DNA is damaged in their in rapid replication and the
replicated cells that are in rapid replication. What causes that? Well, it's not genetics that
caused that, but something got inside that cell and damaged the nucleus, the DNA and the nucleus.
So what is that something? Well, it could be a virus, could be a bacteria. Most commonly,
it's a toxin. So we're exposed to these chemicals, most of these toxins, they get inside the cell,
they can sit there can early until we die, but they can also damage the mitochondria, they can damage
the nucleus, they can damage other organelles in the cell, causing ill health and certainly causing
cancer. So from a preventative standpoint for cancer, I would really look at detoxification pathways
and trying to keep my toxic exposure to a minimum as best that possibly can, then to think about doing
like a GCM AF. So that's what I did. Okay. Okay. Recommended adaptogen that is great for reducing
cortisol and inflammation, but also one that does not increase estrogen. I have a history of estrogen
dominance, uterine cancer, and cannot risk increasing estrogen, but also need to support my cortisol
levels. So I think this question stems off of some information about some adaptogens that can be
estrogenic. So the, I'm trying to think of which ones for that, for more estrogenic than
other ones on maybe it'll come to me, but that can be an issue. But with anything like this,
I would suggest you measure your hormones. So this is something that's missed almost across the
board in, with oncology. I just don't get it. They'll tell women that they're ERPR positive,
or her too positive, but then they'll never measure their estrogen. I just don't, I don't understand
it. I mean, it's just here, you're going to have to take this, this aromatase inhibitor for the
next 10 years, because why? Because that's what we do. When, why do we do it? Unfortunately, the truth
we had that is because that's what the pharmaceutical company told us to do. So in order, if I don't do
this, and I don't recommend this, I can get in trouble, and now I can even be sued because I'm not doing
what's called standards of care. Well, who wrote standards of care? Well, the pharmaceutical company.
Well, aren't there the ones who sell the product that you're trying to push on me? Oh, well, just ignore
that fact. So the truth is is that yeah, you should be conscious of your estrogens, but shouldn't you
measure them? And you should, just doing a Dutch test can be a great test to measure your
hormones. So you don't just have estrogen and progesterone testosterone. You have all these intermediate
metabolites. So you want to look at the two hydroxy, the four hydroxy and the 16 hydroxy esteroids,
that's the E1. And these are the ones that can be issues. The four and the 16 can be issues. So you
want to look at those and measure those. Some people can be exposed to not just different
adaptogens, but other things in their environment that can stimulate estrogen production, or that can act
like Xedon estrogens in their body and not somebody else's. So measuring that can be very beneficial.
So there are different adaptogens that can help reduce cortisol, but I also would recommend that you
measure your cortisol. So, you know, we always think that everything in the body is, you know,
either all good or all bad because we read some article about it or because that's the kind of
the current hype in the natural scene. And cortisol always gets the bad rap, right? Access cortisol,
it's a stress hormone, and we don't want cortisol. And cortisol is my problem. And cortisol is why I can't
go to sleep at night and cortisol is this. Well, you can't blame something that you don't measure.
So that might not be true. You know, there's lots of reasons why I person can't fall asleep at night.
Lots of people reasons why I person, you know, can't lose weight. There's lots of reasons why
that we're giving a bad rap to something. We need to measure it. So measuring cortisol levels can be
very beneficial. I can't tell you how many people that you do a Dutch test and you do a Dutch
complete, which does have a cortisol measurement in it too. And their cortisol levels are down in the
dump. So they have a adrenal fatigue is what they have or adrenal burnout. So their adrenals are
burned out. They're not getting enough cortisol. You don't have enough cortisol. Remember,
everything's not bad or everything's not good. It's about balance. If you don't have a balance of
cortisol in your body, you know, you won't break down glucose. You won't break down glycogen stores.
You will have tons of brain fog in issues because your brain needs glucose in order to feed off.
But if you don't have enough glucose for your brain, especially at night, you're going to have all
sorts of issues waking up at night and such. And it's a decrease amount of cortisol. So we need to
build up the adrenal glands. So then maybe it's adrenal tissue that that person needs not so much
an adaptogen. Maybe it needs they need pituitary tissue to help stimulate the adrenal flow. Maybe
they so there's lots of different things that we want to look at. So we certainly don't want to if
you have a history of uterine cancer or a history of breast cancer, that was horrible driven. You want
to look at zero estrogen. So you want to look at estrogen levels and those bad estrogen levels. So
running a Dutch test would be the best thing to do to really want to measure it. Okay, next question.
What are the benefits of zeolite? And is it worth taking or are there other foods, herbs, minerals
that have the same benefits that could be safer or a more affordable option? So zeolite is really a
key later. So there's a difference between a binder and a key later. So a binder is something in my
definition is something that's really going to stay in your gut here. Not going to really absorb a lot
of it. You may absorb some, but it really does. It's made function in the gut. Now zeolite functions
as a binder because it does bind stuff in the gut. What would it be the purpose of a binder? So why would
you take something that would bind stuff in the gut? So the purpose of that is when your liver
goes, you know, when bad things chemicals flow through your bloodstream, you breathe them in,
let's say you get them on your skin, you spill gasoline on you, you eat something that has chemicals
in it, and you absorb those. It goes into the bloodstream, circulates around the bloodstream,
eventually goes through the liver, and the liver holds it out through phase one, phase two,
and then through phase three detox pathway puts it into bile. It gets secreted through the bile
duct into the gallbladder, and then out into the dewanum, hopefully to be deposited into the toilet
the next bowel movement. Now the problem is, is these toxins can dislodge from the fatty bile and
can be reabsorbed. And we don't want to do that, especially if person has issues with constipation
in things, they may be reabsorbed a lot of toxins. And so you would eat things that act as a binder.
So from a dietary standpoint, things that would act as a binder would be indigestible fiber.
Well, all fiber would actually act as a binder. Indigestible fiber acts also as a fuel source to
the epithelial cells of the lining that line, the intestinal tract could really be a beneficial fuel
for helping those replenish themselves. But fiber can be a binder. So other things like minerals are
humic acid can be binders. There's a sheet that can be a great binder, bentonite clay can be a binder.
So those are mainly some of those are found in foods, but some of those things are found in
supplements as well. Zylite can act as a binder too. So the purpose of a binder again is to grab out
of things in the intestines so that you toxins in the intestines so that you don't reabsorb them
so that they get deposited into the toilet. Zylite also acts like a key later. So a key later would be
something that you absorb and that grabs out of things in your bloodstreams or a bloodstream or
in the tissues and pulls it into the bloodstream to then go through liver phase one, phase two, phase three
and all the way out and get bound in the intestines in the toilet. So zylite acts as a as both of those.
So zylite can be a good key later. Now the process of key lading toxins out of your system,
out of your tissue, sounds like a fantastic idea. Oh, I should do that because everybody's toxic and
boy, I should start taking some key laders. But I highly recommend that you go back and either take
my course on the seven phases of detox because you have to know before you start key lading,
which I call phase zero, you have to make sure phase one, two, three, four, five, six is open and
working well because if you start key lading out of the tissues and you have a backup in the liver,
it's just going to dump that toxin somewhere else and you've not made yourself any healthier,
you could actually make yourself much sicker. So either look at that course, it's super cheap to buy
the course and start watching it. I think I have several videos of that course on our video site.
I think I have multiple blog posts about that also. So look at seven phases of detox. Just go
on our on our website into the blog and search seven phases detox or go to our video site and go
into the search and type in seven phases of detox. I also understand it since I'm talking about that
and it reminded me we were having trouble with YouTube pulling down videos because of
quote unquote medical misinformation in this video will probably pull down because I said something
that their AI will pick up and say this is wrong. We don't approve it. Oh yeah, what did I say to
nice bash the AMA or something like that. So that's not going to go well with them. So
Dustin who works at Cutters Clinic here and that's a fantastic job. That was a good plug wasn't it?
I tried to tell him last week that he volunteered some other therapy. He did a fantastic job in putting
up our own private video site. So we're tired of getting our YouTube videos pulled. We're tired
of getting our information pulled. We're tired of getting the AMA bashing us and all this kind of
stuff. Well we'll try to go completely private. We've always had videos on Brighton and some of
the things like that but personally I don't really go to those channels. We wanted our own video site.
So go to the video site there's links on our website to the video site and that will help you
understand those things. So as far as other options of these are from zeolite that are more
portable options from a dietary standpoint make sure you're in a lot of flavor. And from
just a normal health site perspective you want to make sure that your detox pathways are open and
that has to do with making sure that you're having daily bowel movements at you know at least one
a day yet you're really clear yourself out that your gallbladder is working well and you can take
supplements for that using hot packs over your gallbladder. Learn how to do coffee
animals one of the best things for your gallbladder your liver and your detox pathways and your
anxiety and stimulating your parasympathetic system and all sorts of things. So you'll learn all about
that on that course if you do take the seven basic detox course. Next question first of all thank you
for the very good interview live yesterday with the maker of the true right machine.
Yes thank you we just got that up we actually did that interview a long time ago.
It's been a great resource. I was wondering if you have any experience with using
rife for issues such as skin cancer heart related conditions and stabilizing blood pressure.
Well you could call our office and who will most likely answer is marina and she will talk to you
about using the rife for heart issues because I've written programs for her for that but I
but there are programs under rife for a lot of things so but there's some so understand the rife
is a tool so you got to use a tool correctly you don't use a screwdriver to pound in a nail that's
like you could do it is not going to be very effective so the same thing with the rife the rife is
using light frequencies so if I am let's say I am mercury toxicity and I got to use a rife
machine to detox mercury well it's not going to do anything to key late mercury out of your body
well could I run liver programs would it help my liver function better yes yes it would so indirectly
it's going to help with that it's not going to pull mercury out of the tissues to get to the liver
but it could help your liver work better could I run it on my kitty to help my kitty function yeah well
for sure yes could I kill skin cancer with it yes you can so but there's different types of skin
cancer so the question was the experience you see the rife for skin cancer yes so the more deadly
skin cancer is the most deadly is melanoma so the three most common skin cancers are melanoma
that can be the most deadly squamous cell which could also be deadly and then basal cell which is
rarely rarely deadly so if a person calls and does a case review with me and they have basal cell cancer
would I recommend the rife machine well it really depends on their budget so honestly if you don't
have any cancer and you just want a good healing tool for your house I would highly recommend a
rife machine it can be good for all sorts of things so I don't have any skin cancer what do I have
well my kids my kids get colds or I don't have kids but I get colds I I want to stay healthy especially
in this environment where I'm kind of don't want to want to doctor anymore the rife machine can be
a great tool comes with you know 2500 different programs from anything from macular degeneration to
headaches to inflammation swelling to viruses to bacteria to just whatever you could think of
but it's gonna work better on different things so it's gonna work better on killing living things
it's gonna work better on bringing frequency harmony to your tissues so it can help all your
organs work better but it really shines when you're trying to kill something living you're trying
to kill cancer cells you're trying to get your immune system to attack a cancer cell it can kill
bacteria and viruses and you know pathogens directly because they are you know not a stable
molecule so not a stable organism so let's take viruses out of that classification but viruses
technically are really living they're only reproduce when they get inside yourself but it can help
stimulate your immune system to attack that virus and kill that virus and that's what we need
so it can be a great tool for answer the first question yes it can be a great tool for skin cancer
if a patient calls and they have squabiss cell or melanoma absolutely you got to get a rife machine
if you have basal cell well will a rife machine help yes but I do think you should do other things
topically to basal cell cancer so there's also it's a different therapies that you could use for
basal cell cancer that we have used for essential oils to curcumin cream that we make in our office to
there's some things that you can that are that you can purchase there's a b17 topical cream that
we have in our store and there's some other skin topical creams that people could use as well
as far as using the right for heart-related conditions yes it can be extremely helpful
remember on heart-related conditions I would highly recommend if you have any heart-related conditions
whether people have high blood pressure or a history of in any type of interthelial disorder
to make sure that you go on our website and search for hpilora and read and watch some read those
blogs and watch some of the videos that I created at hpilora because hpilora is a major player with
heart conditions also look at possible Lyme disease and heavy metal toxicity so the three major
players that are causes of blood pressure and heart disease all of all kinds are hpilora Lyme disease
heavy metal toxicities and other product infections that could get under the interthelial
lighting to affect the receptors of the muscles that cause constriction of the muscles so that's what
causes high blood pressure so look at that as well but the right is a fantastic killer of anything
Lyme like I said so it is you should be running hpilora frequency so if you already have a right
and you have these conditions you should be running there's blood pressure program on the right
there's skin cancer programs I think on the right and there's definitely hpilora
the right that you should be running those programs okay so this is a question obviously from a
right user is it normal for the hammer bulb to get super hot while I sleep with it so the hammer
bulb with the right machine is typically used for overnight use it's a it's a tube encased it
it's a it's a tube of a bulb that's I don't know three-quarters inch diameter encased in a maybe
three inch to two and a half inch diameter flexing glass tube and it's meant to sleep at night
that it's meant to protect it so that if you roll over it falls out of bed it's not gonna break
but yes it could heat up typically you got those other covers anyhow and it's under the cover
next to you so it's not getting a lot of hair circulation and yes it heats up
so the older hammer bulbs did not have a hole in the flexing glass so they even got warmer
the newer hammer bulbs now have a hole in the flexing glass to release some of the heat
but if you got a cover I like it's they can still get quite hot so I mean not hot they're
gonna burn you or anything like that but it can be incredibly hot in the middle of the summer so
yes that's normal and there's nothing you can do about it so just make sure you take
it under the hood it's cool enough a second. Typically you're not going to get any problems with it.
And our last question that came in one of the best supplements to take to help prevent colds in
blue we have a product that has you know pretty much everything and it just to simulate
the normal healthy immune response for colds and flu's and you know viruses so that's called our
clear CD clear CD for cold and virus or what do we call it's cold CD for? I don't know not for
corona virus I know it wasn't from there but could be so that was videos for sure getting a fan
so it but the clear CD is something it's one of our bigger sellers it's got big and you're
everything in it you need to help for a virus, clothes, flu's, just stimulate a healthy immune response
obviously there's other things that I am big into for your immune response that would be medicinal mushrooms
one of my favorite for cancer because medicinal mushrooms really act as a immune regulator so
if your hyper immune so if a person has an autoimmune disease you don't necessarily want to take
a product like clear CD on a regular basis. If you feel like a cold's coming on you feel like the flu's
coming on taking it for a period of time a week or two is fine but if you have an autoimmune disease
no you have posh immunos or you think you have not all of your disease or you've been diagnosed
with rheumatoid or something like that then I would not take clear CD on a regular basis
taking mushrooms though can be safer because they're not going to be this immune giant immune
stimulator they will be more of an immune regulator so if your immune system is suppressed because
of an infection then it will help build that white blood cell backup, the cow backup and if it's
overly expressed because of an immune autoimmune issue it could help actually bring it down which
is kind of nice so you don't get that really hyper push of white blood cell count with mushrooms unless
it is suppressed and always I don't think you should look at two and I forget to mention this is
getting some blood work done so getting a CDC and a complete metabolic panel done and if you're a
course member of ours member you could order blood work off our course we don't mark it up at all
and you get a local doctor local to your state that signs off on it so it's all legal and everything
and then you could go get a blood draw I would highly recommend the complete wellness panel
that gives you a complete CDC complete metabolic panel complete thyroid panel and some other
things that could be really beneficial to really analyze an infection or not so if your white blood
cell count is is elevated beyond 7.5 or 8.0 you definitely have a a current infection and then you look
at neutrophils and lymphocytes to kind of give you some discernment whether it's a virus or a
bacteria that gives you a good idea how to best treat that as well so good we answered those questions
hopefully that was helpful for everybody and make sure you go to our site to look at past calls as
well we have those nicely laid out on the holistic health of our site that's did a great job of
putting it into like blog posts and there you could ask questions so jump on that and ask questions
you will be good thanks so much bye bye